[Musique]
et au bout cas tu m'a fait de la peine
allez tu viens sinon
on ne s'approche jamais jamais de la
surface pour c'est clair tout est génial
à la surface tu vas voir la marche l'air
vers le ciel les nuages le soleil non
faut pas le regarder je rigole bien sûr
qu'il faut le regarder le deuil au
village du monde
c'est un peu ma spécialité
[Musique]
sur un poêle à bois
quelqu'un de la chance aujourd'hui
[Musique]
c'est tranquille
donc on allait va créer ton club le klub
des loosers
je m'appelle julian alcoba nous les
rebelles on doit rester solidaires on
n'est pas des rebelles
merci à ton avis c'est pour tuer quoi
ces trucs tous qui loge
l'église et non plus simplement
il ya des minières de choses qu'on sera
incapable d'accomplir
marty suffire et besson
vous êtes très louche tous les deux
c'est trop dangereux
voir je connais le problème table ou non
dans la tête 1 vous nous dites silène
sur blood au silencio blood bowl ha
dilenn sur blood run sur dylan jobe
longtemps encore ok toi c'est tout voilà
allez accroche toi
[Musique]
tu vas jouer au foot mais l'eau à toi
maintenant insidieux et va jouer
ailleurs sous fido